Speaker 1: There is a new report out about
coronavirus in vaccinated people and unfortunately,
as a combination of some poorly written headlines,
as well as people who may be just are not
understanding the math of what's being reported,
there are people reading about this and saying,
oh, no, the vaccines don't work.
I believe that a lot of these folks are just
misunderstanding the math.
Now, the new report from the CDC explains
that out of 77 million vaccinated people in
the United States, it's believed that there
have been 50 800 infections, 396 people who
required hospitalization and 74 people who
died.
And then some of the headlines fomented.
What was the reaction from many individuals
who thought, oh, no, the vaccine isn't 100
percent effective, which we knew no vaccine
is 100 percent effective.
Another reaction was, wow, even vaccinated,
you could end up in the hospital if you get
the virus.
And of course, we knew that as well.
These are incredibly powerful, efficacious
numbers of the 77 million vaccinated people.
Zero point zero zero zero zero nine six percent
died and this is pointing to being one of
the most effective vaccination programs once
we are at full strength that humanity has
ever seen.
Vaccines are not 100 percent protection.
We I don't know how much more of that has
to be said.
The baseline would never be this is only good
if no one ever gets sick.
It's an impossible goal.
It's an unreasonable goal to see this data
and to come away.
Thinking the vaccine doesn't work is horrifying
because this data is really telling us how
effectively the vaccines do work.
And then to get this gets to a lot of black
and white thinking.
That has been a problem during the pandemic
unmasks remember, do the masks work or don't
they?
Either they do or they don't.
They either work perfectly or they don't work
at all.
Well, no, it's a percentage.
If one person has a mask, you're reducing
in a physical sense with a physical barrier,
the spread of the virus.
If two people have a mask, well, then you're
reducing it even further.
The vaccine, it's not one hundred percent.
We understand that if one person in an interaction
is vaccinated, the possibility of spread goes
down because the vaccinated person is 90 percent
less likely to spread and ninety two to ninety
five percent less likely to get it.
So if they they're less likely to give it
to the unvaccinated person, they're less likely
to get it from the unvaccinated person.
If you have two people interacting who are
vaccinated, the possibility of the spread
is even smaller.
And if someone were to get it out of the vaccinated
people, it would be less serious.
And if it were serious, you would be less
likely to die.
That's these are confidence intervals.
That's how everything works.
This really is some of the best news that
we could have hoped for.
And it's important to know there's actually
this these numbers may improve over time.
On the one hand, it's true that of those 77
million vaccinated people over time, as more
of those individuals are out in the world
and are potentially exposed, some more of
them are going to get the virus.
That's true.
But as more people get vaccinated, the interactions
that that cohort of 77 million has is going
to increasingly be with vaccinated people,
and that's going to reduce the contagion even
further.
So we're dealing with a lot of different things
right now.
We've got the pause on the Johnson and Johnson
vaccine.
Countries and the U.S. are still figuring
out to some degree supply and distribution.
We are waiting to see because cases have just
been trickling up, although deaths have been
continuing down, as we said yesterday or the
day before.
We're waiting to see when will we really see
the drop in cases that Israel saw.
Israel saw it somewhere between 50 and 55
percent vaccinated.
We're probably a month from that in the United
States.
Some states are closer, sadly, because of
vaccine hesitancy.
Some states are further away.
But the important take away is how insanely
effective these vaccines are.
The CDC data confirms that and restates that.
And that should really be the focus.
And as we talked about earlier this week,
and we're going to look at tomorrow and tieback
sentiment is declining.
It's not as low as we would like.
The latest Monmouth poll says 20 percent of
Americans don't want to get the vaccine if
they can avoid it, which I guess means if
they need to get it for their job, some of
them would one out of five.
That actually is enough to get us to herd
immunity.
But that's only from adults.
And adults don't include kids.
So if we get to 80 percent of the total population,
we will actually be good.
And we'll look into this in more detail tomorrow.
The anti-tax sentiment being led by Republicans,
43 percent of Republicans say they do not
want the coronavirus vaccine.
So we'll dig into those numbers tomorrow.
But the latest CDC data uncovered in vaccinated
people extremely, extremely
reassuring data.
That is really
the takeaway.